>> My name is Antonio Guterres, I'm United
Nations high commission for refugees. An answer
to your question, I think the most important
is for each one of us is to do what we have
to do and to do it based on values, to do
it based on the best of all capacities. And
then if there are issues that need collective
action, I would select in the present moment,
climate change, and the need to find the medicine
to get, tolerance, the need to make people
understand that societies are becoming all
multi ethnic multi religious multi cultural.
And we need to respect each other to live
with each other and to be able to make the
most out of it. And finally to understand
that the 21st century will be a century of
people on the move. More and more people will
be moving from one country to the other. Some
out of choice, some out of necessity and we
need to be able to provide them the same set
out rights we did for our normal citizens.